difficile d'être adolescents de vivre
confie ni benjamin qui est en secondaire
5 trouve le temps long
je trouve ça dur aussi pour morales
parti tu peux pas voir grand monde
c'était ton cercle social un petit peu
plus faire mine d'habitude je sais les
mettrons pas devant l'autre comme sur
l'habitude pis j'essaye juste de baisser
non sortir je cause des noirs qui se
retrouve bientôt aux écoles il devra
encore patienter le gouvernement du
québec n'a pas l'intention de rouvrir
les écoles de 4me commun ont vont
réouvrir graduellement l'économie les
écoles les services de garde
mais le mot important le silmo graduelle
on ignore pour le moment quand les
classes reprendront benjamin son côté
est triste il ne sait pas s'il aura son
bal de fin d'année tous tes amis tu sais
que tu as connu depuis bientôt 50
s'était taillé pour pas en fait boucler
la boucle avec genre tout avec tombale
tout juste comme l'ordre adultes genre
gel aussi est découragée elle compte les
jours comme s'il était en prison à 5
sort de l'école c'est une journée puis
j'attends j'attends qu'il ya les élèves
déconfinement arrive pourrait pour que
j'aille à l'école et bien à chaque
journée je me dis peut-être que demain
ça va aller mieux mais avec le bon temps
qui s'en vient les prochaines semaines
pourraient être beaucoup plus difficile
pour les adolescents dans des prix mais
l'impression vont commencer un petit peu
la commandite graff signé c'est ça peut
s'exprimer toutes sortes de façons
l'adolescence mme et évidemment ça
risque de s'exprimer pas mal à
travailler rite habilité encore plus de
l'acheter - le goût de participer
le goût est de parler que micky et en
troisième secondaire est inquiète
j'ai vraiment est conseillé avant de la
peine que je commençais vraiment à
devenir dépressif harper parce que chez
moi qui casse sociale vient de ses
parents et mes amis puis je trouve qu'il
ya seulement parler
via facetime pour garder espoir pour
éloigner la déprime
chloé victoire aux tic et une chanson on
voulait motiver les jeunes à notre âge a
même s'ils sont en confinement de
trouver une manière de quand même
s'épanouit ses coups qu'on est la
technologie de nos jours parce que sa
technologie je sais pas comment je serai
benjamin lui gardent espoir qu'il pourra
retourner à l'école avant la fin du mois
de juin
ici jean philippe robien radio canada
montréal